listen y'all country folks clean up good
clean up good
you know okay so first of all the show i
was just talking to fellas telling them
folks are fanatical they're not just
like fans of this show folks are
fanatical so can you even wrap your
brain around that how people have really
just taken to this show and won't let go
i do feel like people get so pulled in
like i feel like half the time my mom
now like speaks to me as if i'm teeter
and i'm like mom you know teeter's
actually she's not real
um
right but i think the show's infectious
and it's infected like all of our lives
and how we live our lives outside of the
show like i feel like all of us are
looking at ranches and land to buy so we
get it it is it's like it becomes a
little bit of an obsession for sure
do you what do we know about the
timeline for season five are we about to
start shooting are we look
oh
i do know that the new season will be
split in two parts
and i know that shooting starts in may i
love that see
what i'm saying
nuggets okay quick ladies i'm gonna have
to let you go but just quickly have you
thought about that moment if you hear
the show's name read what that's going
to be like for you
oh i mean i'll probably go up and speak
i'll probably intro kev i'll talk about
how you know i came in episode 34 and
here we are now